Well, let's go through 1 possible answer together.
We're assigning to the variable, regexp, a regular expression.
Those start with r and then double quotes.
The first thing I want to do is match the function name. That will be [a - z]+.
Now I want to match immediately an opening parenthesis.
I will escape that opening parenthesis just to make sure that it works.
Now I can possibly have spaces or not,
so I could have 0 or more spaces, so I'll leave a space
and then put a star.
The star will refer back to the space, and we can have 0 or more of these.
Then there's a numerical argument--1 or more digits--
and then more space, 0 or more, more spaces.
I close off the parenthesis, escaping the closed parenthesis just to make sure.
Now I'm done, and this regular expression works well in practice.